qu'il est
16h30 nous allons commencer à
l'heure madame la ministre mes chers
collègues nous avons le plaisir
aujourd'hui de recevoir en cette fin
d'après-midi Madame Catherine Colona
ministre de l'Europe des Affaires
étrangères pour évoquer les grandes
orientations du projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 il est évidemment difficile
d'entrer dans le vif du sujet sans dire
un mot du contexte international dans
lequel ce budget sera discuté la
situation prancheorient évolue très
rapidement madameist
vous revenez d'Israël vous nous direz
quel bilan nous devons dresser quelle
perspective vous semble se dégager pour
un apaaisement des tensions régionales
et de la part et la part de que la
France prend évidemment dans ses efforts
nous avons appris hélas que le bilan des
morts françaisue à
s'alourdir sans doute nos collègues
voudront-ils savoir en savoir davantage
sur la situation en Ukraine d'où l'INT
l'attention médiatique s déporté depuis
une semaine le soutien des États-Unis
qui a pu sembler menacer il y a quelques
jours a été été réaffirmé avant-hier par
le secrétaire au Trésor comment ce sout
le soutien européen pourra-t-il
pourrait-il quant à lui être renforcé le
sort des population du hautkarabak est
un autre motif de préoccupation partagé
sur nos bancs en visite sur place il y a
15 jours vous avez annoncé une aide
militaire à l'Arménie et dénoncer une
épuration ethnique depuis le président
alief a boudé le sommet de Grenade le 5
octobre et l'Arménie craint toujours
pour son intégrité territoriale que
faut-il selon vous attendre des
pourparlés qui auront lieu à la la fin
du mois à l'invitation du président
Charles Michel sans doute nous en
direz-vous davantage sur d'autres
dossiers dossiers préoccupants du moment
et je pense que les sujets ne manquent
pas dans ce contexte international pour
les moins chaotique nous nous
réjouissons de la hausse des moyens
alloués à notre diplomatie les crédits
gérés par votre ministère augmenteront
de près de 300 millions d'euros l'an
prochain la mission action extérieure de
l'État affiche une augmentation de ces
crédits de près de 9 % par rapport à
2023 et je laisserai bien entendu à nos
rapporteurs le soin de revenir sur les
détails ta de ces différents sujets
s'agissant de l'aide publique au
développement les documents budgétaires
laissent penser que la commission
d'évaluation de l'APD voulu par le
législateur en 2021 en août 2021 et dont
le décret de fonctionnement est apparu
est paru en mai 2022 pourra commencer
ses travaux à la fin de l'année il
serait temps mais cette échéance
pourra-t-elle seulement être tenue
madame la ministre vous pourrez nous en
donner quelques quelques réponses les
crédits de paiement de notre APD se
stabilisent mais au-delà des chiffres
madame la ministre comment qu' avez-vous
l'aide publique au développement dans un
contexte profondément renouvelé par
l'actualité je songe évidemment au
retrait forcé de notre présence dans
certains États d'Afrique de l'Ouest et à
et à la concurrence que nous y font
d'autres puissances je pense aussi aux
annonces auxquelles ont donn lieu les
événements au Proche Orient avant de
donner la parole à nos rapporteurs pour
avis et aux rapporteurs spéciaux de la
commission des finances je vous propose
Madame le Ministre de nous exposer
succintement les récents éléments
d'actualité que vous pouvez porter à
notre connaissance nous en viendrons
ensuite aux questions budget budgétaire
en commençant par les différents
programmes de la mission action
extérieure de l'État puis ceux des
programmes relatifs à l'aide publique au
développement et enfin tous les
collègues pourront s'ils le souhaitent
poser les questions qu'il le qu'ils
souhaitent je vous rappelle que cette
audition est captée et diffusée en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat
madame la ministre vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
merci de cette introduction monsieur le
Président et veuillez tout d' d'abord
recevoir mes mes
félicitations pour votre
élection les nouveaux sédateurs
recevront également les mêmes
félicitations et les sénateurs réélus a
on droit tout
pareillement je vais très brièvement
évoquer la situation au Proche Orient et
vous proposer de répondre aux autres
points dans les questions qui pourraent
m'être adressé après cette audition
consacrée au PLF
2024 la situation au Proche-Orient est
extrêmement
grave je n'apprendrai rien à personne en
commençant ainsi mais je voudrais
surtout souligner que la France est
active pour éviter un
engrenage qui conduirait à une situation
encore plus dangereuse
elle a multiplié les contacts jusqu'au
niveau du président de la
République avec les pays de la région
avec nos principaux partenaires
européens Conseil européen à distance
s'est encore tenu hier avec les
États-Unis d'Amérique avec le
Royaume-Uni et avec d'autres j'ai fait
deux même et nos ambassades sont
pleinement mobilisées pour faire passer
des messages que nous considérons comme
indispensables à passer et si je devais
les
résumer c'est pour ce qui concerne
l'urgence de demander l'accès
humanitaire à la bande de Gaza des bien
de première nécessité des médicaments
qui sont indispensables aux populations
réfugiées dans le sud en particulier de
demander la protection des civils et de
demander d'une façon générale le respect
du droit international par
Israël dans l'exercice de son droit à se
défendre puisque personne ne doit
oublier que Israël a été l'objet
d'attaque terroristes abominable de la
part du Hamas organisation sont
terroristes commetttant des actes
terroristes dont l'horreur n'est plus à
démontrer et que il a comme tout État le
droit de se défendre et même le devoir
d'assurer la sécurité de sa population
ainsi que le devoir de le faire comme
tout état également dans le cadre du
droit au-delà de ces
questions immédiate et vous avez vu
combien les besoins humanitaires sont
pressents à Gaza le second taxe ce
d'effort de notre diplomatie et de la
France consiste à lancer auprès de
chacun un appel à la responsabilité pour
éviter l'escalade et éviter un
embrasement régional qui pourrait
atteindre peut-être plusieurs pays
ententer peut-être d'autres et ne
laisserit sans doute pas nos propres
territoires totalement à l'écart de
tension que l'on voit déjà à l'œuvre je
veux évidemment
ne pas être pessimiste et ne pas faire
de projection qui le seraiit plus encore
mais constater l'extraordinaire
volatilité de la situation et les
tensions qui d'ors et déjà se sont fait
jour des précautions ont été prises sur
le territoire national avec le
déploiement de forces de sécurité avec
des instructions données tant au
magistrat que pour ce qui concerne nos
préfets ou nos écoles toutes les mesures
de précaution qu'il convient de prendre
en la circonstance néanmoins vous l'avez
vu et je conclurai très temporairement
par là les événements des derniers jours
et pas seulement de la dernière journée
conduisent avoir un risque fort que
commence de se réaliser ce que nous
redoutions ce que nous appelions les uns
des autres à éviter et croyez bien que
les messages les plus clairs ont été
passés je l'ai fait moi-même tout
récemment lorsque je me suis rendu en
Israël à téaviv et Jérusalem dimanche
puis auoker puis à
Beyrouth la préoccupation est donc forte
le Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
néanmoins vient d'adopter cet après-midi
une résolution présentée par le Brésil
et qui a été travaillée comme c'est la
règles au Nations Unies négocié quelques
jours avant d'être mise au au vote et
d'être accepté cet après-midi qui
condamne clairement euh le Hamas et ses
actions terroristes appel à la
désescalade et rappelle aussi les
principes fondamentaux du droit
humanitaire il faudra bien enfin
redonner un horizon de paix recréer les
conditions permettant de restaurer une
perspective de paix car c'est seulement
la paix qui permettra d'assurer la
sécurité des un comme des autres et bien
sûr dans cette perspective il faudra
prendre en compte le droit absolu
d'Israël à la sécurité tout comme le
droit des Palestiniens à disposer d'un
état nous ne changeons pas de conviction
que c'est la paix qui apportera la
sécurité et qu'il faut se diriger vers
une solution à deux états où chacun
pourra vivre en paix et en sécurité que
ça ne paraisse pas un paradoxe que de
parler de paix dans des circonstances
aussi difficiles c'est sans doute
justement dans ces moments où la la
responsabilité la la maîtrise et je
dirais peut-être même la raison doivent
prévalir ir qu'il est important de ne
pas se laisser entraîner seulement par
les événements et de repenser aux
perspectives qui sont les seules qui
pourront durablement amener la sécurité
et la paix et la garantie des droits de
tous voilà monsieur le Président sur une
situation évolutive sur laquelle nous
reviendrons certainement dans dans les
jours qui
viennent
j'ai saluer
les nouveaux
sénateurs cité ceux qui ont été élus à
de hautes fonctions vous me permettrez
monsieur le Président de rendre un
hommage particulier au président de la
commission que fut Christian Cambon
pendant de longues années et avec je
crois l'appréciation de tous en tout cas
de la ministre qui vous parle j'en viens
maintenant à notre ordre du jour qui est
le budget du ministère de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères pour l'année
2024 le PLF 2023 avait permis de
constater un certain nombre de progrès
mais plus encore que le PLF
2023 le budget qui est proposé à
l'approbation du Parlement est un budget
qui est positif je dirais même peut-être
offensif parce qu'il nous permettra de
mettre en œuvre les priorités fixées par
le Président de la République au mois de
mars dernier lorsqu'il était venu au
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères cloreent les états généraux
de la diplomatie que nous avions lancé
il y a un peu moins d'un an et et en
tirer des conclusions et annoncer ses
décisions si votre assemblée l'adopte ce
projet de loi de finance nous donnera
donc les moyens d'affirmer nos principes
nos intérêts et nos solidarités pour
reprendre le titre de la dernière
conférence des ambassadrices et des
ambassadeurs à la fin du mois d'août il
y a quelques semaines et avant de vous
présenter l'économie générale de ce
projet de budget je souhaiterais revenir
rapidement sur le contexte international
dans lequel nous nous inscrivons
non pas hors proche- Orient mais en
complément de ce que j'ai été amené à
dire sur le Proche-Orient CEN est
peut-être une illustration d'ailleurs
mais nous voyons que notre environnement
est marqué par une brutalité
accrue je pourrais évoquer la guerre en
Ukraine qui dure depuis 18 mois les
tragiques événements qui ont cours en
Afrique l'effondrement au Sahel
l'accroissement des tensions en Asie la
situation au Caucase celle au Soudan on
peut-être on parle trop peu c'est un
monde difficile un monde où les règles
du jeu sont moins respectées
qu'auparavant un monde marqué aussi par
le le chacun pour soi où les les les
cadres habituels sont remis en cause on
a vu les divisions au sein du G20 euh on
voit une
gouvernance internationale
contesté y compris dans le domaine des
grands équilibres financiers on voit des
difficultés à trouver des compromis par
par exemple sur le climat les moins
récents n'ont pas été marqués par les
progrès que l'on aurait souhaité voir et
qui sont nécessaires pour la COP 28 on
voit aussi le recul des droits de
l'homme dans de nombreux pays et dernier
élément pour rester là aussi très
général et rapide c'est un monde qui est
marqué par la propagande une propagande
sans complexe et par des manipulations
de l'information à une échelle qui est
bien sûr décuplée par les réseaux
sociaux
tout ceci c'est autant
de nouveauté ou ou d'accélération de
mouvements qui étaient à l'œuvre et
accélération manifeste avec des
conséquences qui ne le sont pas
moins face à ces mouvements nous devons
et nous nous efforçons de combiner trois
lignes d'action la première c'est de
continuer à jouer notre rôle de ce que
le président de la République appelé les
partenaires de confiance nous cherchons
à créer
des coalitions nous cherchons à étendre
nos partenariats sujet par sujet avec
différents groupes de pays nous le
faisons activement en participant à la
résolution des des crises de sécurité
dans dans le caucas en Ukraine nous
sommes actifs je l'ai fait récemment
d'ailleurs en me rendant dans la région
tant en Ukraine que en Arménie euh mais
aussi tout récemment au Proche
Orient sur ce proch Orient nous nous y
reviendrons peut-être mais je redis la
préoccupation de tous bien au-delà de
celle que je vous ai exprimé il est
manifeste que tous nos partenair et tous
les pays de la région en particulier
partagent cette très grande
préoccupation sur les enjeux globaux où
il faut progresser nous voulons aussi
être des partenaires de confiance nous
prenons des initiatives nous nous voyons
comme ayant ce rôle conformément à notre
vocation et nous nous mobilisons sur
beaucoup de fronts climat biodiversité
océan avec la perspective du sommet de
Nice en 2025 finances international avec
la mise en œuvre des conclusions du
sommet des 22 et 23 juin à Paris tout
ceci va continuer de dominer notre
agenda dans les mois qui viennent et
avec une dimension que vous avez évoqué
de partenariat pour le développement des
partenariats solidaires rénovés grâce
aux décisions qui ont été prises dans le
Conseil présidentiel pour le
développement au printemps et le du mois
de juillet avec notamment chacun le sait
la fin des critères géographiques au
profit d'une concentration par objectif
nous permettant mieux de piloter
politiquement l'instrument qui est
l'aide publique au au
développement dans cette atmosphère de
chacun pour soi il faut pourtant aussi
savoir défendre résolument nos intérêts
nous le faisons nous le faisons en
matière de diplomatie économique je
voudrais à ce titre saluer
particulièrement l'action du ministre
délégué qui est Olivier bechte euh nous
avons lancé un un plan export nous
devons continuer euh d'amener nos
entreprises à prendre des marchés et
continuer d'attirer des investisseurs
sur nos territoires nous avons à cet
égard de de très bons résultats puisque
la France est pour la 4e année
consécutive le premier pays en Europe à
attirer les investissements
internationaux mais c'est aussi euh
défendre nos intérêts en développant des
partenariats structurants nous l'avons
fait avec l'Inde le 14 juillet avec la
visite à Paris du Premier ministre
maudit ou en ouvrant de nouvelles pages
comme nous l'avons fait avec la Mongolie
dont le président est venu tout
récemment à Paris après une visite du
président de la
République à la fin du printemps de la
même manière nous défendons nos intérêts
en
assumant nos modèles économiques et en
particulier notre modèle énergétique je
veux à ce titre puisqu'il y a une
actualité récente euh indiquer que nous
avons de bons résultats pour défendre
notre modèle euh de mix énergétique
incluant le nucléaire civil et
correspondant là aussi à nos objectifs
de décarbonation de l'économie je l'ai
fait tout
récemment fin septembre en me rendant en
Finlande pour participer à
l'inauguration du premier pr en
fonctionnement sur le continent européen
pr qui fournit d'ors et déjà 30 % de
l'électricité de la Finlande et lui
fournit donc une not autonomie dont ce
pays avait besoin donc fin de la
dépendance à ses grands voisins et nous
venons de le faire encore avec succès il
y a quelques jours en parvenant à un
accord européen enfin sur la réforme du
marché de l'électricité et enfin pour
mieux réguler et pour mieux défendre nos
intérêts mais je ne fais qu'évoquer là
aussi une grande direction d'action rien
n'est possible sans l'Europe qui est à
l'évidence notre levier de puissance le
plus sûr et le plus puissant donc nous
poursuivons euh dans le cadre européen
l'agenda versaill souveraineté
économique défense progrès de la défense
énergie migration venons-en au budget
euh mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
un budget que je disais être offensif
pour répondre à ce
contexte de plus en plus difficile je ne
vous le cache pas mais vous le voyez
même sans moi le projet de loi de
finances qui vous est présenté acte le R
moment de notre diplomatie grâce à une
hausse de ces moyens hausse inédite
depuis des décennies puisque vous savez
comme moi que et les budgets et les
emplois avaient considérablement baissé
dans ce ministère depuis plus de 30 ans
cette année sont prévus 165 emplois
tempss plein de plus et une augmentation
de nos crédit de 4,5 % par rapport à
2023 budget 2023 qui est déjà marqué une
première inflexion tant sur les crédits
que sur les ETP pour les ETP première
fois depuis
1993 et d'ici à 2027 ce sont donc
700 emplois 700 ETP supplémentaires qui
sont prévus dans le programme
pluriannuel annoncé par le président de
la République sans compter les les 100
de de cette année et une hausse de
crédit au total de 22 %. ainsi en 2024
le budget du ministère atteindrait
6ard765 en crédit de paiement hors
pension soit une hausse de 293 millions
d'euros par rapport au budget de cette
année la mission extérieure action
extérieure pardon de l'État se verrait
attribué à l'intérieur de ce budget
3ard344 millions en crédit de paiement
hors pension et le programme 209
solidarité à l'égard des pays en
développement 3illard 420 millions
également hors
pension ce budget est aussi un budget
novateur en ce que il renforce très
substantiellement la mission action
extérieure de l'État vous le voyez pour
nous donner les moyens de la
transformation souhaité par le Président
de la République dans le prolongement
des états généraux de la diplomatie
cette mission connaîtra ainsi sa plus
forte hausse depuis
2005 avec 11 % par rapport à
2023 ces moyens supplémentaires qu'en
fait-on et bien ils sont mis au service
de priorité de priorités que je voudrais
vous vous présenter qui nous tiennent
qui me tiennent particulièrement à cœur
je ne parle que de priorité je ne
prétend pas donc à l'exhaustivité en
tout cas dans cette intervention
liminaire première priorité les
fonctions politiques y compris sur les
enjeux globaux et je voudrais là me
concentrer d'abord sur le programme 105
qui regroupe les moyens de notre action
diplomatique et crédit de fonctionnement
des ambassades et consulats programme
qui croîtrait de 13 % l'année
prochaine crédits qui nous permettront
de moderniser de transformer le
ministère d'une part en poursuivant nos
investissements dans le domaine
numérique beaucoup on été fait ces
dernières années mais il faut poursuivre
c'est évident pour mettre en place en
particulier de nouveaux outils tout ce
qu'on appelle les outils collaboratif et
moderniser le travail diplomatique
développer nos capacités d'analyse et
d'anticipation grâce à cela d'autre part
investir davantage dans
l'immobilier y compris dans l'efficacité
énergétique de nos bâtiments mais aussi
dans leur sécurité là où il le faut il y
a encore beaucoup de besoins et enfin
renforcer certains services en France ou
certains postes à l'étranger de manière
à mieux adapter les besoins humains aux
besoins ainsi les services de presse par
exemple de nos ambassades ou la
direction de la communication et de la
presse du C mais aussi le protocole qui
joue un rôle crucial dans tous les
sommets que nous organisons verront euh
leurs moyens euh renforcés nous devons
créer aussi la future académie
diplomatique et euh il est apparu
indispensable de renforcer nos plus
petites ambassades ce qu'on appelle les
les PPD il sont 25 postes de présence
diplomatique euh qu'on va renforcer avec
quelques emplois euh parce que
l'expérience montre que ils avaient été
trop réduits en en volume et notamment
en emploi ces moyens supplémentaires
nous permettront aussi de porter une
attention plus grande au quotidien des
agents et de leur famillees ça se
traduira notamment par un effort
supplémentaire en matière de logement
social ou encore par une meilleure
couverture des frais de scolarité à
l'étranger ils ont parfois beaucoup
montés notamment dans les pays où
l'inflation est forte s'agissant du
programme 209 maintenant donc outre
l'aide au
développement et ce qui nous permet de
gérer les crises il bénéficierait d'un
budget s'établissant à un peu plus de 3
milliards d' en crédit de paiement ça
nous permettra de faire face à tous nos
engagements et de rester je le pense le
4e bailleur au monde en aide publique au
développement le caractère prioritaire
de l'aide humanitaire je dis bien
humanitaire a été réaffirmé par le
suicide de juillet dernier cette aide
humanitaire a été monter fortement l'an
dernier il le fallait elle est désormais
de près de 900 millions d'euros et elle
restera à ce niveau si vous l'approuvez
en
2024 ce programme comprend aussi ce
qu'on appelle la provision pour crise
majeure inaugurée en loi de finance
2022 beaucoup développé en
2023 nous l'avons monté à
270 millions et c'était prudent puisque
cette année encore vous avez vu qu'il a
fallu l'utiliser pour que ce soit le
Soudan récemment le Caucase encore plus
récemment ou les réfugiés palestiniens
depuis quelques jours merci
désolé permettez-moi quelques mots
vraiment pour saluer ce dispositif de
provision pour crise majeure il nous a
permis de répondre très rapidement et et
sans passer par des de longs processus
d'arbitrage budgétaire à des à des
crises humanitaires ou à des besoins
humanitaires pressents après des crises
Ukraine Turquie voilà je pourrais encore
évoquer d'autres d'autres cas Libye Gaza
je viens de le dire 100 millions
annoncés
avanthier Arménie je l'ai ditci pour les
populations fuyant le le haut carabac
cela se fait inutile de le préciser dans
le plus grand respect des règles et je
veille personnellement à ce que cette
provision soit utilisée conformément à
son objet hein c'estàd avec des besoins
urgents sur des actions ciblées et qui
ont un impact immédiat quand on
n'importe 5 tonnes par exemple d'aide
médicale en Arménie parce qu'il y a des
réfugiés du gocaba et des grand Bret des
grands brûlet voilà un exemple je pense
de ce qui est utile de
faire le projet de loi de finances qui
vous est proposé reconduit donc cette
provision pour crise
majeure nous accrion aussi
euh un peu plus qu'en 2023 aux mesures
d'urgence d'assistance à l'Ukraine en
partenariat avec les autres
États-membres de l'Union européenne la
facilité européenne de paix qui a été
tout à fait utile deviendra ainsi
bénéficiaire de notre plus importante
contribution internationale en 2024 il
est prudent de le prévoir car la guerre
s'installe dans la durée en tout cas il
faut avoir les moyens d'accompagner
l'Ukraine et de défendre nos valeurs et
la sécurité du continent dans la durée
la coopération bilatérale financée par
ce programme 209 serait quantelle
augmenté de 5 % à 109 millions d'euros
pardon 20 109 millions d'euros soit 5 %
pour un total d'un peu plus de 2
milliard 2liard 1884 en crédit de
paiement ce renforcement de l'aide
bilatérale
abondrait significativement les qui sont
à la disposition directe de nos
ambassades je vais en citer quelques uns
parce que là aussi nous avons essayé
d'innover depuis quelques années lorsque
les expériences étaient positive de
développer ces instruments nouveaux
ainsi les fonds de solidarité pour les
projets innovants le
fspi verrez ses moyens augmentés de 20
millions
d'euros pour atteindre 100 millions
d'euros on reste à l'échelle du
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères dans des volumes tout à fait
raisonnables mais ça a été c'est un très
bon dispositif donc j'ai souhaité
l'accroître le fond équipe France FF
pour que dans une ambassade tous
travaillent dans le même objectif et et
ensemble et le fond d'appui à
l'entrepreneuriat culturel le fac don
vous avez vu peut-être quelques
résultat il y a une semaine 10 jours à
Creative Africa qui sont des dispositifs
d'aide extrêmement réactif aussi créé
l'an dernier bénéficierait quant à eux
de 60 17 millions
d'euros enfin je veux citer le don ONG
qui est alloué à lafd qui augmenteré de
7 millions d'euros en crédit de paiement
conformément à notre volonté de soutenir
les organisations de la société civile
et aux besoins manifestes qui s'y
exprime le montant des crédits consacrés
à la coopération multilatérale
maintenant baisserait très légèrement en
crédit de paiement pour s'établir à
796 millions d'euros mais avant de
recevoir vos critiques sur ce point je
dois les prévenir en indiquant cette
baisse tiens au fait que d'importance
dépenses réalisé cette année en 2023
présentai un caractère exceptionnel et
donc ne seront pas par définition
renouvelé en 2024 je pense par exemple
l'arriérée de contribution au fond
mondial de lutte contre le sida la
tuberculose le paludisme nous avions 70
millions d'euros d'arrièé une fois que
l'arriéré payé il n'y a pas lieu de
prévoir cette dépense au budget 2024
ou je pense à la facilité pour les
réfugiés en Turquie même s'il peut y
avoir d'autres tremblements de terre je
n'ai pas les prévoir dans ce budget donc
20 million d'euros qui n'est pas
nécessaire de prévoir dans au PLF 2024
donc en réalité ce niveau de
796 millions d'euros permettrait de
consacrer des moyens même à de nouveaux
engagements et de renforcer les
contributions volontaire française sur
des thématiques importantes comme le
climat la santé l'égalité femme homme ou
l'éducation autre marge l'extinction
progressive du Fond Européen de
Développement jusqu'en 2027 donc ça nous
permet d'avoir de nouveaux projet à
budget constant sur le
209 deème grande
priorité tout ce qui est lié à ce qu'on
appelle
l'influence en 2024 donc c'est le
problème S 85 la dotation de ce
programme hors dépense de personnel
croîtrait de 50 millions d'euros par
rapport à cette année s'établissant à
721 millions d'euros soit une hausse
importante de 8
%. cette politique d'influence se
structure autour de deux grands axes
d'une part le développement d'un nouveau
partenariat culturel et solidaire avec
le continent africain et d'autre part la
consolidation de l'attractivité
française dans les autres pays
prioritaires notamment dans la zone
Indo-Pacifique n pouront peut-être
revenir sur tous les les enjeux qui se
déroulent un renforcement du réseau
culturel est engagé il le fallait les
dotations aux établissements autonomie
financière principalement les instituts
français les instituts français de
recherche à l'étranger verra leurs moyen
augmenté d'un peu plus de 8 million
d'euros par rapport à cette année de
même les crédits alloués aux alliances
françaises augmenterai d'un mil00on et
dei d'euros soit une hausse d'un peu
plus de 20 % pour les Alliances
françaises pour financer leur
transformation numérique leur permettent
de poursuivre leur attractivité j'étais
hier à l'Alliance française de kishina
en Moldavie et elle fonctionne
extrêmement bien c'est l'une des plus
dynamiques mais aussi pour
euh financer leur mise en en sécurité ce
n'est pas des lieux qui étaient prévus
pour être dur et il faut les il faut les
durcir il faut les protéger davantage et
enfin une hausse des crédits
d'intervention d'un peu plus de 24
millions d'euros euh ciblant en priorité
les postes permettrai d'offrir de
nouvelles marges d'action à notre réseau
culturel et de coopération sur les
géographie prioritaire renforcer le
soutien aux industries culturelles et
créatives financer de nouveaux campus
Franco x Franco ceci ou des résidences
d'artistes on les a beaucoup développé
dans de N pays nombreux pays avec des
formules souples adapté à chaque pays 24
millions d'euros euh cela vous paraîtra
peut-être peu mais c'est une
augmentation de 60 % sur des des
outils l'effet de levier de l'expérience
que nous en avons est extrêmement
favorable dans un contexte de
compétition internationale accrue je me
réfère à ce que je disais au début de ce
propos la politique d'attractivité
étudiante doit faire l'objet d'un
investissementue c'est bien le cas il
faut maintenir le le rang de la France
les crédits à louer au bour B pour les
étudiants étrangers en France serait
porté à 70 millions d'euros soit 6
millions de plus par rapport à cette
année et une hausse de 9 % notamment
pour faire venir des des profils
qualifiés sur les secteurs en tension et
de même une augmentation de 2 millions
d'euros soit plus 15 % est prévu pour
les échanges d'expertise et les échanges
scientifique qui contribue à la
politique d'attractivité de la France on
essaie de remonter le le niveau de ceux
qui qui s'intéresse à nous et que nous
formons enfin avec ses crédits le
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères continuera dev vrer pour
renforcer la place de la France dans le
système multilatéral grâce à notre
contribution aux opérations de maintien
de la paix de prévention et de médiation
c'est ainsi que 6 millions et demi
d'euros sont prévus en contribution
supplémentaire à l'OTAN suite aux
décisions du sommet de Madrid de 2022 et
que nous versons euh 17 millions d'euros
de plus aux différents organes des
nations- Unies trè priorité et là aussi
pour s'adapter à ce
monde en mouvement et et plus difficile
où il faut se se battre sur des lignes
d'action clairement définies la
communication et la diplomatie
publique nous avons déjà fait beaucoup
de choses je crois depuis euh 2 ans euh
si je dis 2 ans c'est-à-dire même euh
avant que je prenne mes fonctions je v
rendre hommage à mon prédécesseur mais
nous accélérons il le faut là aussi
souvent les les crédits de nos services
de presse sont trop faibles et nous
voulons progresser à la hauteur des
moyens que vous nous consentirer nous
avons prévu de faire augmenter ce moyen
de 2
million2 d'euros pour accroître le rôle
du ministère dans le pilotage de la
communication générale de la France à
l'étranger ainsi que les capacités de
nos ambassades avec comme priorité
l'Afrique et l'Indo-Pacifique ça ne vous
étonnera pas la direction de la
communication et de la presse a déjà été
renforcé dans le passé nous continuerons
ce renforcement en moyen humain et aussi
en outil de promotion production même
d'information et de repost dans la lutte
informationnelle et d'une façon générale
nous cherchons à doter ce ministère
d'une nouvelle culture de la
communication stratégique avec deux axes
le premier qui est la dynamisation et le
renforcement de notre présence dans les
médias sur les réseaux sociaux pour
toucher évidemment de nouveaux publics
avec euh j'y faisais référence
l'accroissement de nos capacités de
production audiovisuel mais aussi le
décryptage de l'action diplomatique on
d'être revu un certain nombre de petits
formats euh vidéo euh donc des nouveaux
produits dédiés euh et puis un travail
également avec les influenceurs euh y
compris dans des pays euh sur le
continent africain où on voit que nos
adversaires sont particulièrement actifs
deème axe le renforcement de nos
capacité pour lutter contre les
manipulations développer nos capacités
de veille on ne peut pas tout faire dans
toutes les langues sur tous les
continents partout et et tout le temps
mais nous avons là aussi dû renforcer
les moyens
humains nous avons mis aussi en place un
fond d'innovation pour aider les projets
des postes les plus pertinents dans le
domaine communication et et presse
avec des des plafonds qui sont assez bas
mais
c'est là aussi souvent utile d'avoir à
la main de l'ambassadeur et rapidement
une action qui répondra à un besoin
particulier et enfin puisque 2024 sera
entre autre chose l'année des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques une
enveloppe de 06 million d'euros a été
dégagé à ce titre pour un programme
spécifique d'activation de d'invitation
pardon de de journalistes et pour
accompagner notre communication c'est
évidemment tout le reste des actions de
communication lié aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques qui sont pris en charge
par les autres instances qui s'occupent
de ça c'est un programme spécifique d'où
la somme modeste que je vous présente 4e
priorité les Français de
l'étranger programme 151 donc il
regroupe les moyens de l'action
consulaire et d'assistance au franceç et
de l'étranger en 2024 ce programme
verrait ses crédits hors dépenses de
personnel croître de 24 millions d'euros
par rapport à
2023 ce qui représenterait une hausse de
17 % et un montant de 165 millions
d'euros en 2024 il n'y aura pas que les
jeux olympiqu et paralympique mais aussi
des élections européennes le coût de
l'organisation de ces élections
l'étranger est estimé pour nous à 6
millions
d'euros et donc à ce titre le programme
151 bénéficiera d'une augmentation d'un
peu plus de 1 million d'euros de son
enveloppe qui sera complété par un
transfert en provenance du ministère de
l'Intérieur et des outres merses pour
répondre à ce besoin de environ 6
million d'euros les crédits consacrés à
l'accès des élèves français au réseau
scolaire de la EFE et à la langue
française s'élèvrait à 120 millions
d'euros
120,5 c'est une hausse de près de 15 %
15 pardon millions d'euros par rapport à
l'année dernière enveloppe qui permettra
de financer les bourses des enfants
français dans le réseau de
l'enseignement à l'étranger permettre
aux familles de faire face à
l'accroissement des frais scolarités
j'ai évoqué dans certains pays
l'inflation et pas seulement au
Royaume-Uni et nous avons fait un effort
particulier également sur les élèves en
situation de handicap euh en leur
consacrant 1 million et demi d'euros et
enfin 1 million d'euros financerait
l'instauration du pass éducation langue
française vous souvenez très
certainement de l'engagement pris par le
Président de la République pour
permettre aux enfants de nos
compatriotes scolarisés localement qui
ont besoin certains nont besoin de se
remettre à niveau en langue française de
lancer ce passe éducation langue
française en 2024 et de le faire
progresser ensuite euh la nouvelle
directrice des France à l'étranger des
en France est tant avec nous les crédits
alloués au service public consulaire
ainsi qu'à la modernisation de
l'administration consulaire augmenterait
de
2008 afin d'améliorer la qualité des
services rendus au Français de
l'étranger notamment grâce à la
poursuite du déploiement du service
france-culaire qui sera étendu Madame la
Directrice à l'Europe d'ici la fin de
l'année bonne nouvelle les félicitations
poursuite du déploiement aussi du vote
électronique et finalisation du registre
d'état civil électronique voilà monsieur
le Président Mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs les principales
informations plutôt positives que je
souhaitais porter à votre attention dans
le cadre du projet de loi de finance
2024 2è budget du quinquena qui reflète
l'importance accordée par nos autorités
à la diplomatie française plus encore
que l'an dernier il s'agit bien
d'engager un réarmement nous en avons
besoin c'est un programme qui doit être
un programme plus annuel et je voudrais
une fois que j'ai rappelé cette
nécessité remercier l'ensemble des
sénatrices et sénateurs qui nous ont
aidé à convaincre qu'il fallait redonner
au ministère de l'Europe et des moyens
et des Affaires étrangères les moyens de
ses missions je les mets au pluriel car
elles sont nombreuses merci monsieur le
Président merci Mad la ministerie à ce
titre je voudrais effectivement saluer
la la constance et la présence de
Christian Cambon sur ces sujets qui a
été et qui continue d'y veiller avec
attention euh je vous propose de passer
au de passer la parole aux différents
rapporteurs budgétaire et à commencé par
le p105 action de la France en Europe et
dans le monde et donc je crois que c'est
Jean-Baptiste Lemine qui interviendra
pour les deux rapporteurs merci
président madame la ministre merci pour
cette présentation permettez-moi
peut-être de commencer aussi par par des
remerciements remerciement pour les
équipes du quai qui œuvre en ce moment
même que ce soit au CDCS en centrale et
naturellement sur le terrain on pense à
à taviv à Jérusalem mais aussi à évan
pour prendre d'autres situations
complexes parce que ce sont
effectivement des femmes et des hommes
qui voilà ne comptent pas leur temps
leur engagement pour porter haut nos
trois couleurs et donc les crédits
que nous examinons ils s'inscrivent dans
un contexte mondial que vous avez
largement décrit madame la ministre et
puis également dans un contexte je
dirais propre à la France et et au
moyens affectés à nos différents outils
et notamment à l'outil diplomatique on a
coutume de dire qu'il y a un continuum
défense diplomatie développement force
de constater que les piliers défense et
développement avait été
significativement renforcé effectivement
tout au long des des dernières années
que nous avions mis un coup d'arrêt à
l'érosion des moyens sur ces ces
précédentes années également mais qu'il
était important de pouvoir aller de
l'avant en allant vers le réarmement que
que vous évoquez tout cela c'est
finalement le travail conduit par les
États généraux de la diplomatie de
septembre 22 à à mars 23 avec la
conclusion par le Président de la
République et s'insrivant d'ailleurs
dans une dynamique qui était appelée de
ses vœux par notre commission je parle
sur le contrôle du président Cambon du
président Perin et puis de nos collègues
Jean-Pierre Grand et André gatolin mais
également j'ai en tête les travaux
d'André Vallini sur le sujet
et les résultats sont là pour ce PLF
2024 vous
l'évoquiez nous avons à peu près de
mémoire 146 nouveaux ETP plus 5 + 10 qui
se rajoute sur différents domaines
notamment le le le le numérique euh
peut-être pouvez-vous nous dire quels
sont les les
différents types de fonction et de
recrutement sur lesquel vont être
fléchés ces ces ces nouveaux ces
nouveaux ETP c'est une question qui est
chère à Valérie Boyet qui corapporteur
avec moi sur sur le le programme 105
nous dire également peut-être sur la
mise en œuvre de la réforme de la haute
fonction publique où on en est des choix
qui ont été effectués par par les
différents
cadres du ministère et puis lors du
discours du 16 mars le président de la
République avait annoncé également la
création d'une réserve diplomatique
citoyenne et c'est vrai qu'on a vu le le
succès des réserves citoyennes dans
d'autres dans d'autres domaines
peut-être pouvez-vous nous dire où en
est-on de ce de ce
chantierl autre point cher à à Valérie
Boyer que que que je suppl sur ce voilà
la politique immobilière du du ministère
c'est vrai que allez au début des années
2000 il y avait eu un certain nombre
d'orientations prises visant à à gager
les investissements sur des sessions
immobilières qui n'ont pas été les plus
heureuses il faut le dire et que du coup
après nous avons connu un
sous-investissement chronique et on voit
d'ailleurs ce PLF voilà met des crédits
budgétaires donc ce qui est heureux euh
plutôt que que des produits de session
mais prévoyez-vous un plan qui au-delà
de la sécurisation des emprises et je
sais que jeanvriant était sensible
également à cette dimension là voilà
d'un point de vue immobilier permettent
là aussi de mettre le paquet vous
l'évoqueiez sur notamment l'aspect
développement durable de nos de nos
emprises j'en viens à à à deux points
pour ma part les contributions
internationales et vous évoquiez le le
regain des contributions volontaires de
la France France c'est vrai que ce PLF
acte de mémoire 24 millions d'euros
supplémentaires en la matière c'est
important parce Queen matière de
contribution volontaire on était par le
passé un peu à la traain par rapport à
d'autres États et pouvez-vous nous dire
un petit peu donc vers quel domaine vont
être fléché ces contributions
volontaires et aussi quelque part quel
est le gain d'influence dans l'agenda
des organisations auquell on les affecte
voire dans l'encadrement puisque c'est
c'est un secret pour personne il y a
aussi une compétition assez féroce pour
les postes internationaux euh et euh
peut-être pouvez-vous là aussi euh
illustrer les choses et et et dernier
point sur euh la communication euh vous
l'avez évoqué dans dans dans votre
propos et le président de la République
le 16 mars 2023 euh je reprends ces mots
appelé à changer radicalement d'échelle
euh pour notre dispositif de
communication euh et de modernisation de
nos outils euh c'est vrai qu'on est
rentré euh dans dans dans dans cette
forme de guerre hybride mondialisée euh
et donc euh plusieurs conséquences en
tirer un dans l'analyse et le traitement
beaucoup de sources ouvertes désormais
qui peuvent aussi éclairer peut-être
l'analyse de la situation quid de ce
point de
vue-là deuxièmement on l'a vu sur le
continent africain notamment quit de nos
actions du coup de contre-influence face
à un certain nombre de narratifs qui
sont diffusés de façon assez massive et
quelque part il faut faire de la
communication en mode Close Combat
pardonnez-moi le terme mais je pense que
c'est c'est c'est ça ce que nous devons
faire et puis troisème point en terme de
communication peut-être euh les enjeux
du monde nous les partageons ici ici
chaque semaine dans notre commission il
y a un besoin aussi d'explication auprès
de nos concitoyens euh quelque part
expliquer le le monde près de chez vous
et de ce point de vue-là aussi quels
sont les euh les actions que le
ministère compte entreprendre peut-être
pour décrypter tous ces jeux voilà
madame la ministre monsieur le Président
pour Valérie Boyer et ma
part merci beaucoup je propose qu'on
fasse voulez enfin est-ce qu'on procède
par rapporteur par rapport ou est-ce que
vous préférez de cette manièreel
monsieur le président parons-y comme ça
je vous laisse répondre et puis on on
passera au 151 Rapp par rapporteur merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre de de vos questions
et d'avoir souligné que dans le Nexus
défense diplomatie développement l'outil
diplomatique avait été un peu oublié
mais nous sommes en train de rattraper
ce ce retard
euh la politique immobilière je je
commence par elle pour vous assurer à
nouveau de ce que vous savez la
politique immobilière que vous nous
évoquer n' plus court aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs nous devons donc trouver de
nouveaux moyens d'investir de sécuriser
d'embellir parfois les bâtiments dont
dont nous avons la charge et je crois
que personne ne regrette véritablement
qu'elle qu'elle n'est plus court euh la
réserve diplomatique je vous réponds
rapidement ça me permettra d'être un peu
plus précise sur les autres points
chiffrés qui vous intéressaient euh nous
avons avancé en en ayant nommé un
préfigurateur qui regarde en particulier
comment cela se passe dans des
ministères qui connaissent déjà ce type
de formule de façon à pouvoir me faire
une proposition euh rapidement sur euh
les moyens euh au titre du 105
concernant la hausse de nos
contributions et et la hausse si
possible encore l'ire de notre influence
dans les organisations internationales
en effet nous avons longtemps été un peu
en retard et même il est connu que les
contributions volontaires avaient subi
un un déclin pour dire les choses nous
avons remonté progressivement en en
niveau elle s'élève aujourd'hui à 61
millions d'euros
euh dans ce budget qui vous est proposé
avec un peu plus de 2 millions de plus
par rapport à à 2023 on continue à à
monter ça permet la France de
euh regagner des places dans le
classement des contributeurs volontaires
nous sommes désormais le 10e
contributeur volontaire aux Nations
Unies même si notre pays reste derrière
des pays que vous pourriez juger
comparables comme l'Allemagne le
Royaume-Uni mais la la pente est
favorable ces efforts sont vous avez
tout à fait raison
indispensable dans le cadre de cette
pétition accru que l'on voit se dérouler
partout y compris au sein des
organisations internationales et je veux
faire donc allusion là au soutien que
nous pouvons apporter à nos candidatures
de façon à avoir un certain nombre de
Français dans des postes d'influence
dans les organisations international et
c'est ce
qui nous a incité ces dernières années à
mettre l'accent surtout à ce titre sur
les jeunes experts associés les GEA de
façon à avoir un plus large et à
préparer les cadres de demain et pas
seulement disposer d'un poste de
direction ou deux je crois que c'est une
politique à terme qui est la bonne en
matière
de
politique de développement là aussi le
montant de nos contributions volontaires
donc 2009 a augmenté pour les Nations
Unies cela atteind
340 millions d'euros avec 5 millions
d'euros de plus pour 2024 c'est un
niveau que nous n'avions jamais atteint
donc c'est un niveau sans sans précédent
et là aussi ça m'a parut indispensable
si l'on veut peser sur
les les décisions qui sont prises les
choix stratégiques au sein de ces
organisations qui s'agisse de l'aide
humanitaire mais si on veut orienter il
faut il faut peser donc on a monté
l'aide humanitaire je le disais en
introduction euh la santé nous avons là
aussi des besoins et besoin d'exercer
notre influence euh 20 millions d'euros
de de plus les droits de l'homme qui ont
besoin non seulement d'être défendus
mais promus euh la lutte contre
l'impunité des crimes et développement
pnude en hausse également comme d'autres
et nous allons euh en plus de nos
contributions volontaires aux Nations
Unies et également
consacré d'importants efforts à d'autres
contributions
multilatérales reflet des engagement
pris par le Président de la République
comme le fond mondial sida le programme
mondial pour l'éducation avec près de
362 millions d'euros je l'ai dit de
contribution
multilatérale sur
[Musique]
le la
politique humaine du ministère mais
voilà les
167 5 ETP pardon prévu en 2024 plus ou
moins ceux qu'on pourra récupérer
ailleurs les ce que nous avons fait en
2023 a
constitué une première expérience visant
en priorité l'augmentation des moyens
dans les postes diplomatiques et
consulaires donc plus d'une moitié des
emplois créés en 2023 sont allés au
réseau et une petite moitié à la
centrale cette année est sans doute sur
la même répartition
nous voulons renforcer en application
des grands axes que je rappelais les
fonctions politiques et les fonctions de
communication en
priorité sur essentiellement les
géographies prioritaires comme on dit
donc l'Afrique beaucoup de nos postes en
Afrique n'avaient pas les moyens d'avoir
une politique de communication
l'investissement dans l'Indo-Pacifique
qu'il faut poursuivre et puis bien sûr
le consulaire on sait qu'il y a des
difficultés après le covid et la fin
l'approche de la fin de la pandémie se
traduisant par un afflux de demandes une
difficulté à gérer ces demandes de plus
certains postes avaient réduit le nombre
de TP consacrés à ses fonctions on le
remonte et on déploie de plus ce
dispositif qui est maintenant à l'œuvre
de mission de longue durée qu'on peut
envoyer depuis Paris pour avoir plus de
souplesse vous
m'interrogiez sur toutes les questions
de lutte contre la désin formation ou
action
plus offensives en matière d'information
sur la désinformation
je rappelle ce ce que j'ai dit nous
partions d'un point extrêmement bas par
la force des choses puisque la
désinformation était peu pratiquée et
heureusement jusqu'à il y a peu de temps
qu'elle devient un moyen d'influence un
moyen de de guerre hybride redoutable et
nous l'avons donc mise au cœur de notre
action au sein du ministère avec la
création de cette nouvelle
sous-direction des moyens humains et des
moyens techniques également qui lui sont
dédiés qui permettent de débusquer très
rapidement les opérations de
déstabilisation il nous est arrivé d'en
rendre au moins une publique parce qu'il
était avéré que des organes d'un état
que nous avons nommés avaent été
complice de cette opération mais au-delà
de ça on a des capacités de réposte
Rapid qui sont accru
sans oublier l'importance de la
formation des journalistes parce que
nous ne pourrons pas faire les choses
seules il faut aussi que la presse soit
plus attentive à vérifier les faits
vérifier les sources croiser les
informations et donc pour ça il faut des
médias
indépendants viable évidemment mais
aussi des journalistes bien formés donc
on poursuit le programme avec CFI et on
a demandé aussi à France médiamond de
veiller davantage à s fait à la
lutte contre la désinformation pour
débunquer les fausses informations si je
peux m'exprimer très vilainement en
langue locale parce que ce qu'on fait de
Paris est une chose qu'on demande à une
ambassade de faire en français ou en
anglais est une chose mais il faut le
faire beaucoup plus et on le fait par le
canal de France médiamonde
aussi
pour compléter ma ma réponse je l'ai
évoqué deux fois dans deux conférences
des ambassadries et des ambassadeurs et
puis très brièvement un instant la
création d'une nouvelle sous-direction
et est une petite révolution culturelle
pour lequ d'orsé puisque nous n'avions
pas ce type de réflexe et qu'il faut
développer un réflex plus stratégique et
donc on fera croître sans doute
encore cette nouvelle sous-direction
c'est une lutte permanente ce que nous
faisons nous le faisons à visage
découvert notre métier n'est pas
euh
d'entretenir des fermes à troll ou même
de les créer il y a peut-être
d'autres services ou maisons qui qui le
font ce que fait le ministère de
l'Europe et les affaires étrangères par
définition c'est un visage découvert et
et ouvertement et puis nous voulons
utiliser la future académie diplomatique
qui est en cours de constitution non
seulement pour former nos diplomates et
former des diplomates étrangers mais
aussi pour qu'ell soit ouverte aux
Français qui qui qui s' inéresseraiit et
j'espère qu'ils seront nombreux à s'y
inéresser et donc
diffuser en région et chez des
compatriotes qu' sait attentif au
crisees mais peut-être moins au grand
mouvement de fond une une culture
diplomatique Jose le mot qui dépasse euh
le le le seul ministère de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères voilà Monsieur
le Ministre et Cher Jean-Baptiste
quelques éléments de réponse à vos
questions merci Madame le Ministre euh
avant de laisser la parole à Guillaume
Gontard qui va intervenir sur le p151
français à l'étranger affaires consulair
et au titre également de Renant lel qui
est absent je vous appelle à la
concision parce que j'ai cinq rapports
cinq missions cinq rapports et ensuite
des j'ai des rapporteurs qui aimeraient
aussi prendre la parole et si on fait 20
minutes sur chaque rapport je pense que
nous sommes encore là tard ce soir merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je vais essayer
d'être un peu plus concis donc d'abord
m'exprimer au nom de de ronand legleu
pour le rapport du programme
151 d'abord une question sur les les
politiques de de visa on sait qu'il y a
une forte reprise des demandes de de
visa je vais évidemment vous épargner
l'ensemble des des chiffres euh comment
du coup absorber justement cette hausse
en matière de de traînement on parle
d'une justement d'une crise des visa on
est passé de 818 ETP à 816 ETP euh pour
traiter justement ses visas et donc ne
faudrait-il pas dessiner une vision à
long terme de notre politique des visas
et des moyens qu'il faut lui accorder
pour la mettre justement au service du
rayonnement de notre pays également une
autre question de de ronand legleu sur
l'organisation des élections européennes
lors de votre audition à l'Assemblée
nationale le 10 octobre vous avez
déclaré en 2024 se tiendront les
élections européennes dont le coût de
l'organisation à l'étranger est estimé à
6 million d'euros à ce titre le
programme 15 151 bénéficiera d'une
augmentation de 1,1 million d'euros de
son enveloppe laquelle sera complétée
par un transfert de 4,4 million d'euros
en provenance du ministère de
l'intérieur des outresmes cela fait si
je ne m'abuse 5,5 million d'euros où
seront donc les 500000 € restants et où
ils seront-ils
prélevés voilà pour les questions de de
ronand legleu ensuite j'avais une
question sur la délivrance des visas
pour les les ressortissants du Mali et
du Niger et du et du Burkina Faso le 7
août dernier la décision a été prise de
de suspendre la la délivrance des des
visas pour ces pour ces pays cette
situation a pu être vécu par ces
derniers comme une punition d'autant que
le 11 septembre un courrier était
diffusé au Direction Régionale des
Affaires Culturelles pour leur ordonner
de suspendre sur instruction du
ministère des Affaires étrangères tous
les projets de coopération artistique ou
culturel avec ces trois pays malgré les
déclarations rassurantes des ministres
concernés et du président de la
République l'inquiétude reste vive dans
les milieux culturels et au-delà nous
comprenons que pour des raisons
sécuritaires et pratiques la délivrance
des visas par les services consulaires
concernés et pour le moment impossible
mais quelle décision ser prise pour
revenir au cours normal des choses la
diffrance de visa est aussi un outil de
rayonnement et d'image pour notre pays
et notamment et particulièrement en
Afrique
sahélienne ensuite sur le déploiement de
France
consulaire le dispositif France
consulaire qui est une plateforme
téléphonique centralisée lancée à titre
expérimental voici 2 ans pour traiter
les demandes les plus simples des
Français de l'étranger et soulager ainsi
les postes consulaires a produit des
premiers résultats qui sont très
positifs c'est un service apprécié donc
on pratriote avec un taux de
satisfaction de 90 % pour les réponses
fournies et 93 % pour le délai d'attente
malgré ce bilan le déploiement du
service en Europe et et dans le monde a
pris un certain retard par rapport aux
objectifs annoncés le territoire
européen est couvert depuis le mois de
septembre 2023 et le dispositif sera
étendu au monde entier en
2026 je termine bruno Sido et moi-même
avions dans dans notre rapport l'année
dernière sur le programme 151 identifier
un possible goulet d'étranglement avec
les effectifs des agents de la Direction
des Français de l'étranger et de
l'administration consulaire affecté à
l'encadrement des téléconseillers et
leur nombre est passé de 8 à 14 en 2023
tandis que le budget global alloué à
France consulaire est doublé de 1,9
million d'euros à 3,8 million d'euros en
crédit de paiement cette augmentation se
se poursuivra-t-elle en 2024 pour
accompagner la généralisation du
dispositif
merci monsieur le sénateur vous avez été
concis m' AZ posé beaucoup de questions
j'ai répondrai donc de façon concise si
je veux pouvoir répondre à toutes
reprise et demandes de visa oui elles
ont été importante je l' évoqué
rapidement euh ça s'accompagne d'un
redéploiement des moyens ou des actions
de de ce petit dispositif qui nous
permet de projeter pour la durée de
quelques mois des agences
supplémentaires sans revoir le plafond
d'emploi de de chaque poste il y a
également des raisons dans certains pays
euh où les délais d'instruction des
visas sont plus longs parce qu'il y a
des besoins de sécurité accrus vous
voyez bien les difficultés dans nombre
de pays du monde la vigilance est de
mise évidemment ça n'est pas maintenant
qu'il faudrait la
relâcher sur les élections
européennes en effet j'ai évoqué ce qui
était à la charge du budget que nous
vous présentons complété par un
transfert du ministère de l'Intérieur et
et des autres maires il
manque
quelques
quelques avec les virgule on en a
5800000 j'ai arrondi à 6 parce que comme
vous l'avez vu j'arrondis souvent non
pas la centaine de millions les moyens
du ministère ne sont pas ceux du
ministère des armées mais pour vous
épargner trop de chiffre après la
virgulle donc les comptes sont bons nous
aurons les moyens de tenir ces élections
le samedi 8 juin je saisis cette
occasion pour en donner les dates pour
le continent américain et les Caraïbes
territoire autreem de cette zone compris
et le dimanche 9 juin pour le reste du
monde métropole et autres territoires
autres mè compris
euh France consulaire euh est cinancé
par très largement ce ce ministère
d'autres y contribuent mais c'est l'un
des chantiers prioritaires nous voulons
le faire croîre et et progresser le taux
de satisfaction étant particulièrement
important 90 % d'un bon score pour une
administration je ne parle pas
d'élection on continue à investir sur ce
service enfin et très brièvement vous
avez évoquer la situation au Mali au
Niger au Burkina Faso dans ces trois
pays les coups d'État se sont succédés
et les groupes terroristes armés sont
actifs plus actifs d'ailleurs depuis
qu'il y a eu des coups état qu'avant et
nous devons protéger nos personnels
protéger ceux qui viennent à l'ambassade
aussi nous avons donc placé ces pays ce
qu'on appelle en zone rouge réduit les
effectifs de nos ambassades vous le
savez fermer temporairement les service
de visa nous sommes en train de les
réorganiser et nous avons suspendu une
partie de nos
coopérations dans ces pays et non pas
au-delà nous maintenons évidemment notre
aide humanitaire et j'en viens à ce que
vous aviez en tête en évoquant ce
sujet si nous avons dû revoir à la
baisse nos actions de coopération dans
ces pays ça ne signifie en rien que nous
n'ayons plus de coopération avec les
ressortissants de ces pays artistes ou
non le président de la République s'est
exprimé sur les artistes je ne reprends
pas ces mots mais ça va au-delà et nous
accueillons aujourd'hui dans nos
universités en France près de 7000
étudiants 6700 étudiants maliens
nigériens et
burkinabé aujourd'hui dont une partie
bénéficie de bourse du gouvernement
français donc que les choses soient
claires ils sont bienvenus étudiants
artistes chercheurs et je précise que
jamais ni mon ministère ni la ministre
n'a donné d'instruction qui aurait
conduit à ce que le ministère de la
Culture écrive ce que semble-t-il il a
écrit je vais être très clair sur ce
point merci Madame la
Ministre programme je passe au programme
185 donc Catherine Duma et Didier
Marie merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre oui donc il s'agit de du
programme concerne la diplomatie
culturelle et
d'influence les crédits consacrés à la
diploma culturell et d'influence vont
donc progresser de 50 millions d'euros
en 2024 évidemment on ne peut que que
s'en féliciter c'est une priorité vous
nous l'avez dit qui est la vôtre celle
du gouvernement que l'importance de
cette diplomatie culturelle et
d'influence et particulièrement
évidemment en période de crise en
revanche je voudrais vous interroger sur
un point bien précis sur dans le cadre
de ces 50 millions d'euros de crédits
supplémentaires
8 millions sont fl
vers laefe alors cette hausse va
permettre de compenser un
surcût qui est lié à la réforme du
statut des personnels détachés pour
seulement la moitié c'est-à-dire donc 8
millions alors qu'en est-il de l'autre
moitié de ce surcout de l'inflation de
la hausse du point d'indice qui est
intervenu au 1er juillet 2023 et qui
elle seule va
représenter à peu près 7 millions en
2024 en tant qu'org organismes divers
d'administration centrale c'est-à-dire
ODAC lae ne peut recourir à un emprunt
pour le financement de l'immobilier de
ses établissement en gestion directe
vous le savez un groupe de travail a
d'ailleurs été mis en place pour
répondre à cette problématique pour
autant à ce jour forcé de constater
qu'aucune solution pérenne ne nous a été
donnée pouvez-vous madame la ministre
nous indiquer où en est l'état des
réflexions sur ce sujet et peut-être une
suggestion pourquoi ne pas avoir inscrit
euh des crédits au titre d'une
subvention pour charge d'investissement
ce qui aurait pu être une façon pour
apporter une solution merci
beaucoup merci madame la sénatrice euh
attendez attendez madame la ministre il
y a Didier Marie qui doit s'exprimer
pardon
pardon bonjour madame ministre euh
monsieur le Président merci je viens
d'arriver dans la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées et et je découvre euh ce
programme euh donc je je sera
certainement pas exhaustif vous avez
inscrit dans vos priorités donc la
diplomatie culturelle et d'influence et
que vous ambitionnez de de de refonder
autour des deux priorités que vous avez
mentionné euh je voudrais d'une part
vous poser une question concernant les
Alliances françaises dont les crédits
vont augmenter ce qui est tout à fait
bienvenu au regard des difficultés que
celles-ci on ont pu rencontrer jusqu'à
présent qui s d'ailleurs traduit par la
fermeture de plus d'entre elles et et
donc ces alliances évidemment
contribuent fortement au renforcement de
notre influence qui malheureusement
c'est
érodé ceci étant je voulais savoir si
ces crédits faisaient l'objet d'une
programmation dans la durée et quelles
pourrai être les augmentations à venir
et d'autre part savoir si vous envisagez
d'élargir les possibilités pour ces
alliances d'aller chercher d'autres
recettes que celles euh des cours de
français qu'elle dispense euh ce qui
permettrait le cas échéant euh de
consolider euh leurs euh moyens euh
d'autre part euh vous avez indiqué que
euh cette stratégie que vous développez
s'appuie en partie sur le renforcement
euh de l'attractivité de notre pays pour
les étudiants étrangers euh dans un
contexte de compétition nationale accrue
euh vraiment indispensable que cette
politique fasse l'objet d'un
investissement euh conséquent pour
maintenir euh notre rang or nous
constatons depuis plusieurs années un
décrochage dans dans notre classement la
France qui situ au 6e rang mondial est
aujourd'hui était qui qui était pardon
au 4e rang mondial est aujourd'hui au
6e et donc l'effort en faveur des
bourses d'études pour les étudiants
étrangers en France qui sera par une
augmentation de 6 millions est bienvenu
euh ceci étant cette mesure ne permettra
pas à seul de compenser le décrochage
qui a été constaté aussi première
question sur ce sujet pourriez-vous nous
préciser les mesures complémentaires que
vous prévoyez de mettre en œuvre en 2024
pour renforcer l'attractivité de
l'enseignement supérieur français auprès
des étudiants étrangers deuxièmement euh
le contrat d'objectif et de performance
2023-2025 de Campus France prévoit une
nouvelle modalité de gestion de la
plateforme étude en France un transfert
de cet outil à l'opérateur pour avoir du
sens sous réserve d'une augmentation de
ses moyens humain et technique
pourriez-vous nous indiquer si une telle
évolution est envisagée et si le présent
projet de loi de finance voit des
crédits à ce titre par ailleurs en marge
du rapport sur le
budget je voudrais vous interroger sur
la position que le gouvernement souhaite
prendre suite à la décision de l'Algérie
de mettre brusquement fin à
l'enseignement des programmes scolaires
français dans les écoles privées je vous
remercie de bien
vouloir merci beaucoup madame la
ministre à vousage du França écoles
privé
algériennes en Algérie
ça n'est pas dans le cadre du budget
madame la sénatrice Duma la la question
que vous posez sur la situation de la
EFE pour le budget 2024 doit
être comprise dans le cadre de ce que
nous avons fait 2023 et je veux rappeler
qu'en 2023 nous avons en effet pour 20
millions d'euros attribuer une
subvention pour charge de service public
à l'opérateur c'était un effort
considérable pour compenser la
revalorisation du point d'indice et ceci
a été fait à cette hauteur en PLF 2024
il a été demandé à la fe
d'internaliser les surcouts restants
liés à la revalorisation du point
d'adice donc en
effet
environ pas tout à fait 7 million
d'euros et comme à tous les opérateurs
ainsi qu'aux administrations publiques
un effort est demandé pour le
redressement des comptes publics ça ne
vise pas particulièrement la EFE mais
également tous les autres opérateurs par
ailleurs et c'est une façon de compléter
ma réponse des travaux sont en cours
vous le savez pour identifier une
solution plus pérenne et et sécuriser
plus durablement la trésorerie de la EFE
nous faisons l'identification de cette
solution une priorité dans nos relations
avec la direction du budget je ne peux
que vous encourager madame la sénatrice
à ouvrir l'esprit de la direction du
budget à ce qui sera une bonne action
pour la EFE et pour tous ceux qui l'
fréquente monsieur le sénateur pour ce
qui concerne les Alliances
françaises souvent très utiles enfin
elles sont elles sont très diverses
elles sont diverses
si je dois les les juger honnêtement je
ne les connais pas toutes loin s four
parce que elles sont nombreuses avant
d'être differses mais es sont dans des
situations en tout cas différentes c'est
pourtant un très bon système qui permet
je DIRIS sur le plan budgétaire en tout
cas d'avoir un très fort effet de
levier donc avec peu de crédit un impact
qui est souvent bon voire même très bon
est-ce qu'elles ont d'autres recettes
que les cours elles peuvent avoir
d'autres recettes que les cours par
exemple lorsqu'elles font passer des
examens main c'est le cas aussi à
l'Alliance française de kishinao et de
tant d'autres mais c'est essentiellement
dans le cadre de leur programmation
culturelle qui leur revient si elle est
attractive de trouver des occasions de
recettes supplémentaires c'est
d'ailleurs ce que toutes ou presque
toutes font et donc les choses évoluent
plutôt bien nous avons par ailleurs une
programmation dans la durée qui va
effectivement jusqu'à 2027 dans les
projections que que nous faisons sur sur
les bourses l'augmentation des bourses a
pour objectif
de nous permettre d'attirer de de
meilleurs élèves et un niveau
correspondant à des gens qui peuvent
peut-être apporter davantage à leur pays
d'ailleurs lorsqu'ils y reviennent et
aux nôtres en attendant comment aller
plus loin ça n'est pas tout à fait dans
le cadre de l'action de mon ministère
mais il faut que nos universités et la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
vous répondrait de façon plus complète
mais avec je crois les même réflexion il
faut que nos universités s'adaptent
continuent de s'adapter pour être plus
attractive que nos partenaires voisins
et et amis et notamment dans le cadre du
programme bienvenue en France je sais
que Sylvie rotillo est très attaché
parce qu'il faut là aussi monter en
gamme très clairement pour
regagner non seulement des étudiants
mais de l'influence c'est bien
l'objectif de ce programme euh quant à
l'Algérie je ne feris pas de
commentairire ici dans le cadre du
budget c'est une décision euh
algérienne qui concerne donc ce pays
euh nous avons euh des relations qui
sont euh bonnes avec l'Algérie mais cela
non non le président tboun Me l'assuré
encore il y a quelques semaines lorsque
je l'ai rencontré à New York donc
comment au nations un comment ne pas le
croire vu l'éloignement géographique
relatif de l'Algérie mais tout de même
nous avons des élèves qui sont inscrits
au kned ce qui permet par parenthèse
d'avoir dans les programmes toute la
gamme à laquelle vous
aspirez merci madame la ministre je
passe au rapport suivant rapport spé
rapport de la commission des finances
donc rémie ferra Nathalie Goulet nétant
pas
présente
il est plus
là bon ben on va gagner on va gagner
rapport on croyait l'avoir vu on savait
que Nathalie nétait pas là mais ben
écoutez on gagne rapport
ministre alors mission mission est
publique au développement Christian
Cambon et Patrice jolie donc je la place
pas trop Christian Cambon pour commencer
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre pour les propos sympathiques
vous tenu à mon endroit et je voudrais à
mon tour redire et compris pour nos
nouveaux collègues vous donnerz acte du
fait que depuis votre arrivée c'est
quand même depuis cette date que les
crédits du
kedoret non seulement se sont stabilisés
mais se sont accrus notamment en matière
de TP et donc je je je je voulais le le
souligner parce que la Commission
l'apprécie évidemment avec mon collègue
Patrice jolie donc nous avons la
responsabilité de rédiger de préparer ce
rapport aide au développement vous poser
une question précise une question plus
générale tout d'abord stabilité des
crédits donc par rapport aux efforts qui
ont été consentis depuis 2017 je
rappelle que les crédit aides au
développement ont augmenté de 50 %
depuis 2017 donc il s'agit d'un effort
tout à fait conséquent en revanche il y
a quelques il y a un point qui nous
interpelle puisque comme je ne reviens
pas sur le point que le le président a
évoqué tout à l'heure à savoir la mise
en place de ce fameux comité d'experts
j'espère qu'on va en voir le bout et
qu'avec la complicité entre guillemets
de la Cour des comptes et de son
président on va enfin arriver à une
solution je ferme cette parenthèse mais
elle est elle est tout à fait
d'actualité en revanche on se souvient
que la la loi du 4 août 2021 avait ciblé
trois trois priorités d'abord le le
rapport entre le bilatéral et le
multilatéral le le rapport entre les
dons et les prêts tout ça ce sont des
sujets qui depuis des années sont
abordés en commission et le ciblage des
pays prioritaires et donc qu'il avait
été précisé à l'époque je rappelle dans
ce dans cette loi dans cette loi que 25
% de l'aide programmable devait
bénéficier à ces pays prioritaires or le
suicide qui s'est tenu en juillet
dernier a purement et simplement
supprimé la liste des pays prioritaires
de cette aide bilatérale au profit d'une
C beaucoup plus générale qui fixe à 50 %
les financements bilatéraux vers les
pays les plus avancés mais les pays les
plus avancés c'est 50 pays les moins
avancés pardon excusez-moi les les pays
les moins avancés c'est 50 de pays et ce
n'est plus tout à fait les les fameux 19
pays prioritaires notamment les pays
africains et donc ma question précise
est de savoir d'abord par quel calcul
vous allez réussir à honorer quand même
le texte de la loi qui reste toujours
valable et queles conséquences
effectivement tout ça peut avoir parce
que bien évidemment pour tenir cet
objectif de 25 % la méthode va être un
tout petit peu plus compliquée donc ça
c'est une question qui a lieu qui porte
sur
l'organisation du du du suicide la la
deuxième question elle est plus générale
elle fait suite à une interpellation que
une centaine de sénateurs ont adressé au
cours de l'été au président de la
République et qui ne visait absolument
pas à remettre en cause le travail
formidable qu'on fait nos no nos
militaires au Sahel mais qui tient
compte simplement d'une situation dans
laquelle nous sommes en grande
difficulté dans nombre de pays africains
et euh qui nous oblige peut-être sans
doute très certainement à revoir ce
fameux équilibre que Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine évoquait tout à l'heure les les
les fameux 3D hein et notamment la
dimension coopération militaire donc je
voulais savoir où vous en étiez de votre
réflexion sur ce sur ce sujet c'estàdire
comment la France va redéployer sa
politique en Afrique à la fois pour
maintenir son influence faire en sorte
que les points qui nous restent acquis
ne soient pas perdus et comment va-t-on
traiter ce ce ce ce nouveau problème
puisque nous sommes sur le plan
militaire en en en difficulté dans
plusieurs pays enfin nous avons du reste
quitter le Mali le Burkina et nous
sommes en train de quitter le Niger et
je voulais à ce sujet vous interroger
plus spécialement sur la politique de
l'AFD je je vais évidemment revoir avec
Patrice jolie avec la plus grande
attention la manière dont laafd qui a
toujours conservé une grande
indépendance y compris vis-à-vis des
ministres de tutelle euh mais comment
laafd va concourir à ce à cette
réflexion à ce redéploiement à ce
réexamen de la politique africaine de la
France parce qu'elle est un outil
absolument essentiel elle a fait un
travail tout à fait extraordinaire mais
je pense qu'il y a des des des réexamens
qui sont tout à fait nécessaires en en
relation avec la situation de ce
continent africain je vous remercie
madame la
ministre merci
Christian merci Monsieur président
madame la ministre un sujet l'aide
publique au développement j'aborde avec
humilité mais je sais que le président C
Cambon m'accompagnera dans dans dans nos
travaux de deux questions qui portent
sur la situation deux situations
spécifiques celle qui qu'on connait en
Afrique et celle du du Moyen-Orient pour
ce qui concerne l'Afrique la France a
suspendu son aide au développement à la
fois en direction du Mali du burkunfasa
par pardon du Burkina Faso du du Niger
donc en raison des des PCH je souiterais
savoir ou avoir des précisions sur les
critères appliquer pour mettre en œuvre
ces décisions qui ne sont pas sans
conséquence bien évidemment et et je
voudrais savoir également si l'aide au
développement à destination de la Guinée
et du Soudan aussi concerné par des
pches en 2021 a également été suspendu
sinon pourquoi et par ailleurs quel
périmètre exact de ces
suspensions est-ce que cette suspension
concerne uniquement les projets futurs
qui seraient annilés ou est-ce qu'elle
concerne également les projets qui ont
déjà débuté et est-ce que les projets
portés par les ONG ou par les
collectivités locales qui pratiqu la
coopération décentralisée sont également
concerné ou est-ce que ça concerne
uniquement l'intervention de l'État en
gros bref il est--il une doctrine
précise qui permet de mieux euh répondre
aux interrogations des ONG et et de
l'interrogation de nos collectivité le
deuxième point concerne donc le
situation des territoires palestiniens
et où une grande partie d'autreide passe
par l'Europe ou par les les Nations
Unies et à la suite des événements du 7
octobre dernier l'Union européenne a
d'abord annoncé suspendre l'aide au
développement et ensuite corriger à
travers en évoquant la simplement la
notion de révision de l'aide apportée
aux Palestiniens et pouvez-vous
aujourd'hui nous en dire davantage sur
le processus en cours et par ailleurs
quelle conséquence là sur le le le volet
bilatéral de de notre aide au
palestinien pardon excusez-moi bien
madame le ministre je vous laisse
répondre et puis ensuite on passera
au suivant merci monsieur le Président
euh monsieur le sénateur Gambon je vous
remercie d'abord d'avoir salué l'effort
considérable qu'a fait la France en
matière d'aide au développement depuis
2017 ça lui permet avec cette
augmentation de 50 % en 6 ans de se
situer au 4e rang des bailleurs
internationaux euh c'est un un beau
résultat et surtout un un bel effort
merci là aussi au Parlement de l'avoir
non seulement approuvé mais souhaité par
la loi d'août 2021 euh votre question
euh concerné le nouveau mécanisme
permettant de respecter cette loi euh
pour lutter contre les inégalités
mondiales et ne pas
oublier de répondre aux besoins des pays
qui en ont particulièrement besoin
la
révision des critères de la aide au
développement euh passant d'une
géographie particulière avec une liste
de 19 pays qui bénéficient parfois un
peu de d'une logique de reconduction non
pas automatique mais de reconduction euh
alors qu'ils sont dans des situation
tout à fait différente a été abandonné
au profit d'une logique de d'objectif
avec des les 10 objectifs décidés en
conseil et qui sont publics pour éviter
que ce changement de de de logique alors
que les PMA restent évidemment
prioritaires et que leurs besoins sont
par définition importants euh nous euh
avons décidé de fixer cet objectif de 50
% précisément pour que euh la démarche
par objectif ne conduise pas
volontairement à des effets d'éviction
ou du moins ne conduisent plus à
répondre suffisamment aux besoins des
pays qui en ont particulièrement besoin
mais ceci vous pourrez le contrôler le
principal avantage de ce changement de
dispositif c'est un pilotage plus
politique et vous l'avez appelé de de
vos vœux et vous continuez de le faire
en souhaitant que les derniers éléments
de la loi soi mis en œuvre mais aussi de
permettre de fonctionner en fonction de
ce qu'est l'adaptation de notre
politique vis-à-vis des pays africains
j'en viens à votre 2è question sur euh
euh
l'influence et et la réorganisation de
nos moyens à laquel nous nous procédons
en peu de mots monsieur le sénateur il
faut se garder de considérer que le
Sahel représente toute l'Afrique le sel
est dans une situation particulièrement
difficile économiquement sur le plan
sécuritaire au combien en terme de
pauvreté souvent et d'état de droit
encore plus puisque des coups d'État s'y
succède dans chacun de ces
pays bien avant ceci et et les demandes
successives de telle ou telle jeunte le
président de la République
avait
poursuivi la réorientation de nos grands
axes vis-à-vis des pays africains
engagés là aussi depuis le début de son
premier mandat en demandant d'accélérer
et de faire si je schématise
terriblement davantage de partenariat
d'égal à égal davantage d'action au-delà
des gouvernements avec lesquels bien sûr
nous entretenons par définition des
relations davantage action vers les
sociétés civiles la
jeunesse les jeunes entrepreneurs aussi
et dans une approche
d'investissement puisque c'est une
nouvelle couche de population que nous
voulons fréquenter connaître et don nous
devons également souhaiter qu'ell nous
connaissent mieux VO même qu'ell nous
comprennent mieux parallèlement à cel ca
cette nouvelle politique s'accompagne
d'une réduction de notre
présence militaire en faveur
d'une priorité nouvelle donné aux
actions de de formation mais également
aux sessions de matériel pour continuer
de faire que les africains soient les
premiers concernés par la maîtrise de
leur destin je crois que les événements
nous ont plutôt donné raison à ce
titre
sur le Mali le Burkina Faso et le
Niger je le disais tout à l'heure nous
maintenons évidemment tout ce qui est
humanitaire monsieur le sénateur je vous
réponds
voilà je le redis et si tel ou tel pays
je peux penser au Mali complique le
travail des des ONG dans le domaine
humanitaire parfois l'entrave et parfois
réussi à l'empêcher ça n'est évidemment
pas sur décision française est-ce que ça
concerne les projets en cours ou les
nouveaux projets ça
concerne l'ensemble des projets y
compris les projets en cours est-ce que
ça concerne seulement les actions de
l'État ou au-delà de l'État ceux qui
pourraient participer à son action Union
européenne ou
collectivité locale et bien ça concerne
là aussi l'ensemble ce sont des
situations sur lesquelles je reviens pas
parce que je les ai décrites qui nous
ont conduit à devoir constatant la
dégradation sécuritaire constatant la
dégradation de l'état de droit prendre
ces décisions donc il y a des raisons
tout à fait objectives euh à cela si ces
pays devaient retourner sur un chemin
démocratique ce qui est évidemment
souhaitable et souhaité bien sûr nous
pourrions réviser notre positionnement
au Soudan euh nous ne faisons que de
l'humanitaire mais nous en faisons
euh beaucoup au Soudan et dans les pays
avoisinants qui ont dû accueillir des
millions de réfugiés en provenance du
Soudan et nous en faisons également en
Guinée ainsi en Guinée puisque son
comportement à notre endroit est
différent je crois que chacun le voit
bien nous avons maintenu quelques
actions de
coopération voilà messieurs les
sénateurs merci Madame la Ministre les
concernant l'aide publique au
développement les rapporteurs spéciaux
de la commission des finances n'étant
pas présents
je vous en prie et monsieur le Président
merci de de me rendre la parole euh pour
préciser ce qui s'est passé il y a une
dizaine de jours euh au sein de l'Union
européenne ou du moins au sein de la
commission avec non pas l'annonce par
l'Union européenne ou même pas par la
commission d'une décision de suspendre
l'aide aux population palestinienne mais
l'annonce par un commissaire sans en
parler à qui que ce soit au sein du
collège et les décisions de la
commission sont collégiales de ce qui
correspond à son sentiment profond
depuis quelques années sur le sujet
chacun le sait qui était de suspendre
toute aide non seulement ça n'est pas
pertinent et donc ça ne s'est pas fait
puisque cette décision surpris ses
pairres comme elle a surpris la
présidente de la commission mais compte
tenu de la situation l'Union européenne
a décidé d'accroître l'aide qui va
directement aux populations
palestinienne très souvent l'aide
nouvelle comme la précédente passe par
le can
des organisations des Nations unies ou
de ces organisations spécialisées unera
PAM par celui du CICR ou par celui de
nos
ONG merci
madame je donc comme je le disais les
rapporteurs de spéciaux de la commission
des finances n'étant pas présent nous
gagnons à nouveau deux interventions
malheureusement avant de laisser la
parole j'ai trois demandes de de de
prise de parole avant de Laer la parole
au à mes collègues j'aimerais juste
peut-être avoir votre réaction à la
décision
en tout cas au au rejet de la résolution
du Conseil de de conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU la résolution brésilienne avec un
vote favorable de la France mais
vraisemblblement un vote contre des
États-Unis et un vote de 12 favorable de
12 pays sur 15 en dehors de la Russie
euh à l'instant peut-être vous
pouvez-vous nous en dire un enfin sur
notamment la position des
États-Unis en en effet monsieur le
Président je décrivais tout à l'heure
les des l'état des des négociations qui
avait
permis d'améliorer le projet de texte
présenté il y a plusieurs jours par le
par le Brésil et de l'améliorer dans le
sens que que je
décrivais le vote et ce vote était
composé d'éléments importants je l'ai
rappeler tout à l'heure et donc nous
avons voté en faveur de ce texte comme
beaucoup d'autres États deux autres
États membres du Conseil de sécurité se
sont abstenus et il y a eu un véau en
effet fait celui des États-Unis
d'Amérique un véteau qu'il leur faudra
expliquer parce que si le texte
n'atteignait pas la perfection des
objectifs qu'on pourrait idéalement
fixer une résolution des Nations Unies
de façon à ce que ce texte amène la
désescalade et euh empêche un engrenage
encore plus délicat tout en rappelant le
droit d'Israël à se défendre il nous a
paru suffisamment bon comme à la
majorité des membres du conseil pour
qu'il soit voté donc un choix différent
d'une autre qui a été fait par les
États-Unis il faudra qu'il qu'il
l'explique et nous aurions préféré
inutile de le dire un consensus on
imagine bien les rapporteurs ayant
terminé je laisse la parole au
commissaire une question une minute
Hélène conwouret pour
commencer merci monsieur le Président
alors comm nous avons épuisé les les
questions budgétaires je voudrais
revenir sur deux points euh qui sont
très importants pour les familles
francophones et francophiles au Niger et
et et en Algérie et vous dire d'abord
dans un premier temps que les bonnes
nouvelles sont très rares en ce moment
et que nous ne pouvons que nous réjouir
de de l'augmentation des budgets que
vous venez d'annoncer je crois que c'est
important de de le noter aussi ravi de
voir que certains crédits
supplémentaires que je demandais chaque
année sous forme d'amendement notamment
les 1,5 millions pour les Alliances
françaises pardon au 10 millions pour
les bourses sont enfin approuvé donc
j'auris d'autres amendements à proposer
je crois cette année dans lors du débat
deux points euh je vous interrogeis en
août dernier sur la suspension
temporaire enfin elle avait été annoncé
comme tel en tout cas des visas des
bacheliers des lycées français du lycée
français La Fontaine à niamet qui avait
obtenu des places dans les universités
françaises et grandes écoles alors là
vous avez euh mentionné madame la
ministre que plus de de 7000 étudiants
boursiers viendraient des pays donc du
Sahel y compris le Niger mais ces
familles ne sont pas boursières donc je
voulais savoir si euh il y a une comment
une ouverture ou une dérogation qui pour
pour être donné à à ces familles qui ont
besoin de de visibilité et le point sur
sur l'Algérie il y a quand même 3000
élèves algériens qui sont concerné par
la décision du gouvernement algérien qui
lui est propre donc il n'y a pas de
commentaire à faire sur ce sujet
cependant nous voyons une forte
augmentation des inscriptions au lycée
français international Alexandre Duma
euh
et la France aurait proposé je vais le
mettre conditionnel aux autorit é
algérienne d'ouvrir un second lycée
français à Alger j'aimerais savoir euh
quel est l'état des discussions à à ce
sujet c'est très important pour les
familles d'avoir une visibilité sur la
scolarité de leurs jeunes merci merci
Hélène Olivier
cadiic euh merci beaucoup madame la
ministre pour ce budget offensif et puis
donc pour euh la définition de vos
priorités je voudrais revenir sur un
premier sujet qui est le passe éducation
euh depuis que je suis élu ma priorité
c'est de faire en sorte que nous ayons
tous un objectif partagé c'est que tous
les enfants français nés à l'étranger
parlent français on voit que 50 %
d'entre eux nés aux États-Unis en
Australie au Sénégal 2 tiers en Amérique
latine 80 % en Israël ne parlent pas
français et ça je dis ça parce que on a
peut-être observé que des Français
d'Israël en ce moment euh parlent en
anglais sur nos chaînes de télévision et
donc ce cet amendement pour avoir un
chèque éducation pour l'apprentissage du
français dans le programme 151 c'est un
amendement que je faisais tous les ans
et grâce cette idée grâce à notre
ministre Jean-Baptiste Lemoine son
collaborateur à l'époque Christopher
weisberg qui est devenu député grâce à
leur soutien c'est devenu un projet du
président de la République et grâce à
votre action vous l'avez mis dans le
budget cette année ce pass éducation va
pouvoir être concrétisé alors je
voudrais d'abord vérifier puisque je
vois qu'il y a 1 million d'euros qui est
prévu pour ce pass éducation ça c'est
pour les écoles flammes donc les
associations flammes ça a été indiqué
dedans euh ça ne fait pas appel au cours
de français proposé par les Alliances
françaises et l'Institut français donc
ça c'est un un premier point alors que
normalement il pourrait aussi fournir
des des cours de français je voudrais
m'assurer que dans la création de ce
passé éducation ça reste respecte bien
un petit peu le le souhait qui avait été
émis par le Président de la République
et Frédéric petit vous l'a dit la
semaine dernière lors de votre audition
il a dit j'aimerais bien que ce soit pas
une usine à gaz on aimerait bien que ce
soit un système sur lequel on on puisse
tous s'impliquer donc j'aimerais savoir
si vous seriez d'accord pour que les
parlementaires aident votre
administration pour justement créer ce
système et s'assurer que les conseiller
des Français de l'étranger puisse
comment dire participer à ce son son
fonction
l'exécution de son fonctionnement merci
et puis la dernière question c'est
concernant bon alors très bien alors on
respecte le truc je suis désolé mais bon
faire respecter règlement la parole est
à Philippe folot merci monsieur le
président madame la
ministre nous sommes dans un monde et on
s'en rend compte chaque jour un peu plus
qui est difficile compliqué
dangereux et et par rapport à cela la
France a toujours eu la volonté la
vocation d'incarner le fait d'être une
puissance globale j'ai eu l'occasion à
quelquefois de revenir sur des injeux au
regard du fait que entre la stratégie
indopacifique de notre pays et la
réalité des actes il y a parfois
beaucoup d'écarts mais il y a aussi des
secteurs sur lesquels nous sommes
j'allais dire relativement
invisible et et et somes tout assez peu
présents même si ce ne sont pas des
zones du Monde qui aujourd'hui sont
marqué par des conflictualités très très
importante et je pense à l'Amérique du
Sud j'avais eu l'occasion de vous dire
et avec mon collègue Catherine Duma nous
avons mené une mission il y a quelques
mois et et et dans ce cadre là nous
avions notamment insisté sur le fait que
alors que la France est une puissance
d'Amérique du Sud par la
Guyane que par rapport au sommet de
l'Amazonie euh notre pays puisse être
représenté à un certain niveau nous
l'avons été par l'ambassadrice de France
euh à à Rio euh très honnêtement alors
qu'il c'était des chefs d'État d'autres
d'autres pays
euh et même si nous sommes pas membres
de la Conférence nous étions invités euh
il y a une différence quand même et un
élément qui pose problème et et et et et
je profite de de ces éclairage sur
l'Amérique du Sud pour vous redir euh
combien nous trouvons dommageable
j'espère qu'au niveau de ce budget
peut-être vous allez pouvoir nous donner
de bonnes nouvelle mais que nous n'ayons
pas toujours la perspective d'ouvrir une
ambassade au Guyana euh pays qui qui par
les richesses pétrolières qui ont été
découvertes va devenir j'ai je dire le
pays les plus riches d'Amérique du Sud
dans d'ici quelques années euh et et et
avec le fait que tous les autres membres
permanents du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations Unies ont des ambassades dans ce
pays et pas encore nous merci Philippe
madame la ministre j'insiste à nouveau
effectivement moi je suis complètement
en accord complet avec ce qui vient
d'être dit et on a fait une mission au
Brésil un certain nombre de nos
collègues se sont déplacés donc
Catherine Duma et Philippe folot avec on
a beaucoup beaucoup insister pour qu'ils
aillent au Surinam et au Guyana parce
que c'est maintenant qu'il faut y être
c'est pas dans 2 ans 3 ans ou 4 ans
quand ils seront très riches et qu'on
viendra récupérer des choses de manière
très intéressée et vraiment moi
j'insiste sur cette question on a
beaucoup de gens qui sur place attendent
une présence diplomatique plus
importante et des des des des des gestes
je je pense beaucoup plus importants de
la part de de la France donc je je je
soutiens vraiment ce qui vient d'être
dit c'est important et on l'a souligné
très fortement dans le rapport qui a été
fait sur le Brésil au mois de juillet
merci Madame et et je m'excuse par
avance mais je devrais partir à écart
donc je laisserai Catherine Duma
continuer la présidence merci beaucoup
je m'efforcerai à la à la concision
monsieur le Président le le sénateur
folio a déjà eu l'occasion de me faire
part de ce sentiment qui est euh
ancré chez lui comme chez vous sur le
Suriname et et les enjeux autour de la
Guyane madame la sénatrice Guyana Guyana
autour de notre Guyana gu j'ai bien
compris mais ça nous intéresse aussi
parce que nous sommes nous sommes pas
loin et autour de nous il y a des gens
madame la sénatrice conoué
Mouré le la situation du du lycée
français
euh de de Niamé est largement dépendante
de la situation à
Niamé et nous nous efforçons de trouver
des réponses en priorité je le dis
d'ailleurs pour les bacheliers à EFE du
lycée français de Niamé en en plus des
boursiers dans le cadre de nos capacités
actuelles pour ne pas dire des capacités
résiduelles qui sont les nôtres au Niger
et vous savez que l'ambassade si elle
n'est pas fermée elle est ou ouver nous
n'avons pas fermé l'ambassade
contrairement à ce que l'on a dû faire
par exemple au Soudan cette ambassade
est sous blocus et donc de façon très
concrète il
est voilà il est plus ou moins sous
blocus et on ne peut pas y entrer ou en
sortir non plus librement ce qui
complique considérablement le
fonctionnement des services qui
pourraient y rester donc espérons une
évolution positive mais on est en train
de chercher des réponses cas par cas sur
sur pour ses élèves euh pour ce qui
concerne votre seconde question oui
l'Algérie nous avons un projet qui est
un projet de de à terme d'ouvrir un
autre lycée si cela était possible et si
la demande était suffisante ce qui est
nous semble-t-il une assez forte
possibilité en plus de lycée Alexandre
Dumas nous en avons parlé d'ailleurs aux
autorités algérienne et nous
continuerons de leur en parler monsieur
le sénateur Cadic le passe éducation
française progresse cet engagement du
Président de la République car s'en
étetin
euh va pouvoir commencer d'être
expérimenter cette année grâce à ce
premier euh euh million sur le programme
151 il s'agit de maintenir souvent de
renforcer les compétences en langue
française des enfants français vivant à
l'étranger avec ce que l'on va créer en
2024 qui est un dispositif
d'apprentissage sous format numérique et
s'adressant dans un premier temps aux
élèves niveau primaire donc les enfants
de 6 à 11 ans première expérimentation
ce sera lancé en 2024 je ne peux pas
vous dire à ce stade exactement quand
puisque nous sommes en train de de
concevoir l'ensemble du
dispositif nouveau
euh programme sans effet d'éviction de
programme au sens non budgétaire sans
effet d'éviction sur le programme 151
donc c'est je pense une très bonne chose
vous souhaitez que ce ne soit pas une
usine à gaz nous avons aucune intention
que ce soit une usine à gaz et donc je
vous ferai la même réponse ouverte sur
la l'association sous une forme à
trouver des conseillers défensés
d'étrangers même réponse ouverte que
celle que j'ai faite au députés petit
l'autre
jour Monsieur le Sénateur
folot merci de votre question parce que
il est important de savoir que dans la
réunion qui a eu lieu première quinzaine
d'oû sur l'Amazonie il y avait deux
parties un sommet des États membres de
l'organisation
régionale puis une conférence et la
France n'étant pas membre de
l'organisation régionale n'a été invité
qu'à la conférence elle n'a donc pas été
absente d'un sommet où il lu serait
reproché par certains de ne pas avoir
assuré la présence qui convenait mais
elle a participé au niveau des autres à
la conférence nous n'étions pas invités
au sommet je veux vraiment là-dessus
être tout à fait clair
sur les projets futurs je ne vous dis
pas non vous m'en avez déjà parlé je
sais pas si c'est dans le cadre du PLF
2025 que nous en reparlerons mais
effectivement ces pays méritent notre
attention nous avons à l'heure actuelle
comme priorité l'Afrique où il y a
beaucoup à faire c'est un euphémisme et
l'Indopacifique où il faut investir
d'avant avantage nous investissons cette
année d'ailleurs dans l'Indo-Pacifique
en ayant augmenté de quelques emplois un
certain nombre de nos postes
diplomatique et prévu d'ouvrir un petit
poste diplomatique PPD aux îles Samoa
courant 2024 lequant plutôt l'habitude
de fermer des consulats pas encore des
ambassades mais des consulats que en
ouvrir c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
et nous n'excluons pas si les budgets
continuaient d'être bons de progresser
dans d'autres
géographies
il y a des enjeux géostratégiques dans
tout le Pacifique et la Chine y est fort
active d'autres aussi mais nous
souhaitons l'être et nous devons
l'être bien merci Madame la Ministre
est-ce qu'il y a encore un collègue qui
va veut intervenir une question une
minute non alors écoutez ça ça sera
court mais un grand plaisir je voudrais
madame la ministre vous remercier de
nous avoir aujourd'hui parlé des grandes
orientations de la loi de finances pour
2024 je crois que c'était
particulièrement important pour nous ici
au Sénat dans cette commission
d'échanger avec le gouvernement dans une
période qui évidemment est très complexe
une période de crise vous avez
d'ailleurs abordé la situation au
Moyen-Orient mais aussi aussi vous avez
pu parler de de l'Ukraine et du haut
cararabak en tout cas on vous remercie
d'être venu devant nous et puis on se
félicite je crois que je peux le dire au
nom de tous mes collègues de la hausse
des moyens qui sont alloués à la
diplomatie parce que ça c'est
particulièrement important et on
veillera à ce que ça perdure merci
beaucoup et bonne soirée à tous
merci